mark you see that one person's life can
be changed by watching episode of the TV
series we have you mentioned that news
voice yes why I'm everywhere as a kid
that a single episode of a single TV
show could change you forever it could
make you a better person it could
inspire you it could even define the
pattern of your entire life for the
better and but of course that has to be
an episode that's written from an
emotional truth it has to be very
powerful very well done and it has to be
something you've never seen before
something fresh and certainly Outer
Limits and Twilight Zone in Star Trek
were filled with those kind of episodes
when I saw city on the edge of forever
on star trek by Harlan Ellison it was
astonishing because in that episode
curtain goes back to 1930s he falls in
love with Edith Keeler played by Joan
Collins and then he learns that in order
for the history to work out the way it's
supposed to she has to die and so he not
only lets her die he stops McCoy from
saving her he physically holds him back
so she can be hit by a truck and this is
in the 60s when every TV show was of
course the girl's life gets saved of
course love triumphs of course the hero
certainly the hero is not responsible
for an innocent woman being killed and
so you know essentially Kirk commits
murder you know with with forethought
and I said to see that to see that that
the message that episode was there was a
larger good and you must sacrifice the
thing you most dearly loved for other
people for other people and that's a
profound statement I mean you know if
you look at what Martin Luther King was
doing what what Gandhi was doing they're
there they're living from that truth
that you have to sacrifice everything
for the larger good and even if it's the
ultimate sacrifice you do that but it
was that one hour of television that
taught me that incredible lesson
profoundly because it had courage in an
emotional courage it had artistic
courage or when I saw in Twilight Zone
walking distance or kick-the-can or I
the beholder or on on outer limits
soldier or demon with a glass hand these
are amazing pieces of work so I started
saying even as a kid even if you know 9
10 11 12 years old looking for the guys
writing these I became fascinated with
who these guys were I wanted to meet
these guys I wanted to learn these guys
and ultimately I did Harlan Ellison and
Ted sturgeon and matheson and all these
guys became mentors of mine Bradbury and
then I went from Rod Serling of course
profoundly so so I take that as a huge
responsibility on me as an artist so
when I sit down to write I'm trying to
create something truthful and fresh and
original and and and and I'm very aware
that there are many successful people in
this industry who don't have feel that
obligation at all one of my teachers was
Bruce Joel Rubin who wrote the movie
ghost he though
wonderful writer wonderful man and one
of the things he said was that he said
most movies and TV shows when you ask
but they're about well like my movies
are about well most movies are about two
hours and that's it maybe they're not
about anything he said most writers and
producers and directors making any film
or TV show have no clue what it's about
and so it ends up being about nothing
it's just empty entertainment and so we
watch a TV show we watch a movie it's
like okay well that was diverting it was
like a movie it was like a dope it was a
dark green death popcorn in but doesn't
change your life doesn't move you
profoundly no and so you start as the
creative artist with the decision to do
something truthful so it's not about oh
I'm gonna change the world it's just
about okay I have something I want to
say and I'm gonna try and say it
truthfully and move people and I've been
very lucky to have that experience a
number of times when I did Star Trek new
voyages world enough in time which
people can watch on Space Command movie
comments in its entirety
that's the Star Trek episode with George
Takei that I did without a studio or a
network I showed that with George George
Takei and I went to the world science
fiction convention in Japan was very
funny because I said George when we were
shooting I said I was very hard shoot
and I said a year from now you and I are
gonna be in Japan I'm gonna showing this
to an audience of several thousand
people you're gonna and then we'll
answer questions I'll be asking in
English you'll be answering in Japanese
speaks Japanese fluently and I said I
hear from them from that living
nominated for the Hugo which is the top
of war in science fiction and that's
exactly what happened but to show that
that on a big screen to an audience of
three thousand people and get a standing
ovation with people's you know it's here
his streaming talent their face to have
Japanese guys come up to me in tears
saying how much they loved it whether
they were speaking Japanese and I still
understand what they're saying because
they're so moved and you know if I was
told that Japanese audiences almost
never give anything a standing ovation
so that was a huge honor so I knew I had
taken something
from my deepest place in my heart and
done my job done my job and so I'm very
proud of that episode and and that's
what spurred me to do Space Command so
so I am honored to do the job I do but I
also sense the obligation to do the job
I do then I feel strong of the
obligation of my audience so so you saw
the vision yes yes well you know the way
it works okay here's how writing works
okay so whether it whether it's like
when I was saying to George that any
year will be a world Connor than a year
after that would be no Hugo or any of
this stuff it's basically you have an
idea in your head so it starts with a
creative idea so it might be I want to
do this big story of you said in outer
space about how we go out into the solar
system and then of the stars and you
know so you start with that as an ocean
that's then comes okay how am I gonna
get this done how many gets made and
this like that becomes okay Who am I
gonna pull together how am I gonna get
it give money how what the logistics
then it's how am I gonna get besides the
world because for me Michael is a rider
is taken emotional truth from my life
and communicate it authentically and
well to a large audience and for me
that's a hundred hundreds of thousands
or millions of people so for me just
speaking personally doing something in
the 99th and 98th cent I didn't know
theater won't serve my objective because
I want to get it out on a big stage so
that's where the internet is so great
you can reach millions of people but so
once that starts with the idea then it
becomes the execution and then it
becomes the distribution and so
previously it was always the studios or
networks but now it can be the internet
it can be video on demand if me a lot of
other methods and some enormous ly
grateful that this new techniques new
technologies and emerged digital cameras
vinyl caught on a Mac all this stuff the
good part innocently is I'm proud of
myself is that I'm
happy to embrace the new technologies
I'm not a lot of my friends there's
someone mentioned the way things used to
be that they can't learn the new the new
methods they can't embrace the new ways
of doing things and so they get stuck
where they're dependent on the studios
to make their dreams come true and
that's sometimes it works and it's
something for my friend Rockne oh man
and he's got two shows shows two new
shows on Network great that's fine but
for most people it doesn't work and and
they're just you know hating the head
against a wall and so again if you if
you know what you're doing it for then
you can remove a lot of things that
aren't serving you we should time I was
talking about rejection on the question
about the Twilight Zone book yeah I
could talk about is that's a big one
with people being rejected in June you
went back to saying some of your friends
have this worldview of sort of old
studio model yeah I think a lot of
people even in Generation X Generation Y
have this with night shining on approach
to their premiere yeah in what way in
the sense that we if you just have that
big break like we'll be dreaming that
penis so some tastemaker will put a
stamp of approval we want you want the
fairy godmother to tap you with the ones
you know you want you want it to be easy
you know and you know and sometimes you
go
okay yes let's talk about that for a
minute okay because okay it's wonderful
when you have dreams and glory as a
creative artist as a writer a filmmaker
director producer whatever and the fairy
godmother comes into your life and she
taps with the wand and everything is
perfect and everything is easy and you
never have to shed tear this rarely
happens first of all and I don't mean to
burst your bubble but fairy godmothers
are not real they're imaginary creations
so but many of us would would love it's
like oh my god well if only JJ Abrams
you know read my script it loved it and
then suddenly I'm on top of the world
right now first of all because I know a
lot of these guys it ain't like this
it's like this the whole career is like
this and food Guillermo del Toro my dear
friend Guillermo he you know his dream
project is a project called at the
mountains of madness it's based on a
novel by HP Lovecraft he's wanted to
make it for 20 years and last year or
about two years ago James Cameron write
on the heat off of Avatar said you still
want to make that let's make that and he
came aboard as producer gamma spent
couple years developing an active
development studio studio development at
Universal Tom Cruise was slated the star
was Ron Perlman who gamer works with off
and he started help away because we was
gonna be a 3d amazing film and the
studio wouldn't greenlight
200 million dollar movie or rating or
rated movies ever made that you know
made that much and you know they just
wouldn't do it
so here's guillermo garibai tell
tomorrow James Cameron Tom Cruise you
think of course they should they're
gonna say yes no heartbreak heartbreak
and then you just go on to the next
project you just keep going and maybe
that movie will get made and maybe it
won't and you know all of us have those
projects let's dream projects don't get
made but if you say to yourself well you
know you know I'm gonna go to
Kickstarter I see what's gonna
inevitably happen ultimately is some guy
some a-list guy some huge guy he's gonna
come to crowdfunding it's gonna come to
Kickstarter or IndieGoGo and it's gonna
say okay I need 50 million bucks and
that's gonna happen and then the world's
gonna change the world is absolutely
going to change because you know I mean
when I was when I was growing up Orson
Welles was still alive and I always
thought thought that there should be a
box on the income tax form that just
said if you want to give a buck to have
Orson Welles make a movie check this box
and then just and then he wouldn't have
that spend the last several decades of
his life in frustration never making a
movie he just would have gotten the
money and make movies because he was
this genius and we would all be better
having these guys making their movies so
but the point is that for all of us this
rejection for all of us there's
disappointment and then it just becomes
how committed you are to what you're
doing and and you know
and again it goes back to if you don't
need to be rich if you don't need the
studios and the network's you have to
really look at your dream and say what
is my dream and if you if you slice it
up into little pieces and you say okay
wait a minute
do I need this piece of the dream or
this is the piece that I really care
about because then it allows you to
maneuver you know and like and also
another thing that we do all of us is
like for instance Guillermo you know he
might do one project and that doesn't
even realize but he might take something
from that project and put it in another
project for instance the vampires he
developed in Blade 2 he ultimately
fluent much more fully realized in the
strain which was a series of novels with
you they've done more recently so and
what I'm doing in Space Command is I'm
taking certain elements from various
projects and then putting them into this
into the umbrella of this project simply
because they fit they work they're great
characters or great aliens or whatever
so that so it's not that that you're
recycling in any negative way but you're
certainly looking at the things that you
care about and making sure they get to
the audience just a business to make
sure I didn't sure yeah let's talk about
that because I really want to talk about
rejection because I think for every
filmmaker I mean most people get bummed
out and they stop you know and they go
home they live lives of sadness and
bitterness and you know then they have
kids they take it on their kids their
kids work to be sad go to people you
know generations you know it's like you
know so I mean it's important remember
that Hitler was a frustrated artist
doing couldn't hit people the pies
painting so he ended up you know
becoming this dictator we don't want
that we want any year people who's
anyone who sees this to do that so I
digress it's almost the Bible or I
well yes it's you know but again it's
like what are you doing it for it what
do you need and what's woody in it for
you know I mean we all have to be
applauded we all have to win and succeed
it's it's right it's very hard to lose
you know
no let's thought was talked about before
it penny we understand that the Twilight
Zone campaign was rejected what 25 yes
over two year period it was rejected it
was projected 25 times over two year
period and that's where it's very
important to have something called a
wife because Elaine said to me just keep
going just keep going and but also when
something's not working you have to
analyze why it's not working and fix
that because until you really figure it
out you can't change it and so what was
going on in that point was my book agent
was Rod Serling's book agent she had
been rats from his book ages so the
millionaire agents she represented Peter
Benchley he was doing jaws at that time
and so from so so she would submit the
book and the publisher would say well we
like this but we don't have to sell it
we know what this market for it and she
wouldn't be convincing them she wouldn't
be selling them on it and and also it
would be submitted to an older editor or
an editor who wanted to buy it but then
I'd have to go to an older publisher who
hadn't grown up with the twilights it
wasn't a fan of the show and we didn't
understand why anyone would be to book
about a show that was already off the
network you know they've been off the
network for over a decade so so I fired
I fired her she was amazed that little
pipsqueak like me would fire her but I
did and I got another agent and it was
the agent who was coming
a book editor which is starting a saying
she was hungry and she's young
and aggressive and she went back to one
of the publishers that are rejected at
Bantam she went to a different editor a
guy named or when Apple valve was a
young you know amazing guy just starting
out but he had the power to buy books he
didn't have to go to anyone from for
permission he grew up with file eyes and
he loved it so he bought the books in
the 26 submission it sold and it was an
instant bestseller and it's been in
print ever since so but the rejection is
very hard which is why you need to
surround yourself with people who are
supportive of you it's cool allow your
dream you must also make sure that your
work is solid
if the film's have to be good most most
writing is not very good most films are
not very good and you have to look at
that with a very hard and discerning eye
and and if you watch it and you say well
wait a minute these actors aren't very
good so maybe I need that's a director
to learn how to work with actors and
maybe I need to go to better actors
maybe I need to well you care what tells
a great story because it all boils down
to how committed you are to your work
and Guillermo when he was doing Kronos
first of all his his writing teacher
said to him if a road is not presented
you build one and Guillermo in Mexico
there was no infrastructure to do the
kind of movies he wanted to make to
spend ten years building a makeup
effects and special effects company as a
vendor to others so he would make his
first film Kronos and then we were
shooting shooting Kronos there was one
shot he wanted which is the inside of
this device with all this gears and it's
a little weird creature in the center of
that device and you plan to build it was
about this big and there'd be a little
miniature camera that would have a
little little cable that would go and
move around in this little thing and
this producer said we do not have the
money to make that shot you're gonna
have to lose that shot and dare mo
really want that shot so what he did was
he sold his van
and he didn't have the money to do that
shot but we dimmed the money to us there
was a junkyard and it had these enormous
gears from some factory that were the
size of a room we bought those gears and
painted them gold we made this big
creature that was like the size of a
Volkswagen we put in the middle of those
gears and then he actually had the
full-size camera move between those
things so people to see that shot it
supposed to be this big and it was
actually the size of a room but that was
Guillermo willing to sell his van to get
that shot so question with anything
you're doing is how committed are you to
what you're doing and you have to be
very committed and because you might be
rejected 25 times we might need to play
six that magic will happen and doors
will open and a cure will be made and
but you also have to be willing to have
that happen again and again and again
and and and anytime you say it shouldn't
be this way what you have to say instead
is it is this way
what am I going to do about it that's
how it works do you think it's harder to
break into the business or maintain in
terms of breaking into the business I
view myself as a burglar working a
neighborhood where I have to keep
breaking in and breaking in and breaking
in so it's not one it's not just once
and it's not like all of a sudden you're
through the golden door and you know
you're serving you pate it's basically
it's you know it's like it's coming up
with things staying fresh finding the
things that excite you being open to the
world learning new things telling new
stories not just going over the same
material over and over again recognizing
what you love I mean Ray Ray Bradbury
was very good with that heat everything
she kept he kept when he was a kid he
was collecting with Buck Rogers
newspaper strips this comic strip and
some kids ridiculed him in throughout
his collection and he realized he made a
terrible mistake and he spent years
building that collection back up and
it's funny because as an adult he was
once speaking somewhere like in Big Bear
and someone said to him I have I collect
those two and I can give them to you if
you'd like them and he in got them and
and so from him I learned to honor what
you love and and come from that place
and really recognize your own unique
qualities because that's what makes you
an individual as an artist so but again
it's you know you're gonna get knocked
back and you're your biggest dreams are
gonna fall to to disaster and ya just
gonna be moments where you just
wanderings you know as if you've been
you know sucker-punched and you know and
that's again when you must have people
who know what what they're doing and you
call them you say okay I'm lost here on
what do I do
how do I do this and you know because
you don't go to people who hire you and
you don't say that the people who hired
you say if the friends you've gathered
over the years you know what they're
doing and that's where it's so far and
have mentors and and and often it can be
a two-way street so for instance someone
might be mentoring me but they'll be an
area that I know how to do that they
don't we're all say okay here's how this
works and so it's very much a two-way
street tell us about the Talent Search
for Space Command and using the
Kickstarter backers yeah well
Kickstarter I mean the thing about Space
Command is I'm gonna be making a series
of films and it's a big epic story it's
been over 200 years in our future
exploration of the solar system out into
the Stars it's basically about two
families the camera family and the
Sikandar family and we go over several
generations with them as all these
amazing things happen in our future so
it's lots of special effects big canvas
epic story and we're jumping at various
points some of our stories are very far
down that timeline some are closer to
our own time and it's not so it's not a
linear chronology it's it's very much
and so there's gonna be a lot of roles
and so I'm casting a lot of my friends
Armin shimerman from deep space 9 I
worked on deep space now and a lot of
other shows even Phillips who played
Neelix in Star Trek Voyager
amber Benson from Buffy and Doug Jones
from Pan's Labyrinth and Hellboy these
are all people that you know I'm writing
roles for they're playing aliens and
androids and all sorts of stuff and but
I also you know I was thinking about it
and I was thinking about Kickstarter is
very much the public the audience the
fans are every bit as much of this
creative process as we are and it's a
very much a two-way street and I'm not
I'm not arrogant about that at all I'm
not I'm not the big guy on the on the
pillar The Dispensing wisdom you know
that's not that's not my role I it's -
it's a it's a two-way conversation I'm
enormously grateful whether someone
gives me $5,000 or $1 thank you you know
that money or inherited or where they
get to get that money somewhere I'm
grateful so I thought I was thinking
about I think okay let's this is
participatory and we think any affects
people contacting us and makeup people I
thought well how can I make it as
participatory as possible and there were
two roles but I hadn't yet cast I
haven't really plugged any of my friends
in on those roles and I thought okay one
of them is the lead
commander matt Kemmer of the of the
spaceship paladin and and there was a
young member of the crew
cadet Bradbury and I actually named that
that character from the beginning it was
way before ray passed away but because
this is this is so inspired by Ray
Bradbury's work in Heinlein and Asimov
an officee Clarke but particularly Ray I
named the character cadet Bradbury and
and so I decided well we have anyone in
the world to the audition for these
roles we they can go on the Space
Command website they can pull down
scenes that we call the sides to
audition with and they can just put a
video on YouTube it doesn't have to be
you know like a movie it can just be
they're auditioning and making put them
YouTube and we and our backers on
Kickstarter on Space Command can vote
and we'll narrow it down to five
each and we'll you know
then we'll have a second round and it's
just kind of like and also another thing
I'm gonna be doing this certain actor
said well what about us we're not we
don't fit either of those roles so I'm
actually gonna write scenes for a
character call the other and then people
will be able to audition for that role
to where it's like anybody any size any
age any race any anything they can
audition for that if they don't suit
them and and also I made cadet Bradbury
non gender-specific so it can be a male
it could be a female because again I
thought well that's fun that's
interesting and because I'm very
inclusive and I and I recognize that
then that wonderful brilliant person
well for instance minds of the Star Trek
episode a world left in time I cast a
lead actress from a very successful show
and she was very very good and in four
weeks before we were gonna shoot this is
after six months of building the team
she sat down with me said I've just been
told I have to have surgery I cannot do
this role and I went white and that's
again where Hughes will have a wife
because Elaine said don't worry we'll
have auditions that someone better will
come in through that door and there was
an actress named Christina Moses who had
never done television never done film
she only done stage she done stage in
New York and she came in and she
auditioned for the role and cast her in
the lead opposite George Takei playing
George's daughter and she was the best
actress I ever worked with she's
phenomenal and then she's so good that
for two years I was banging on JJ Abrams
saying you got to check this actress out
you gotta watch itself so finally he
emailed me said you were two years ahead
of us you're absolutely right he put on
a talent deal and she was auditioning
for the leads at his shows so that's how
amazing that was
and she and I cast her in the lead in
Space Command too so so knowing that
someone with no TV or film credits could
be the most phenomenal actress I've ever
worked with
I learned why one thing I try to do is
learn from what happens in my life so I
learned that lesson
now the Talent Search came about and so
I'm thrilled with what's gonna happen
you know it can be you know and when you
talk about that big break in that fairy
godmother moment you know those don't
often happen but sometimes they do and
and when they happen it isn't just the
the unknown person where it's a great
gift to them it's great gift to us
because we get the gift of their talent
you know themselves who they are that
works great so come come
comic-con is a hundred fifty thousand
people descending on San Diego and I'm
gonna be in the middle of it come the
people come consiguió comic-con have
been kind enough to give us a panel
we're gonna be having a panel it's going
to be actors who we have in the show
it's gonna be producers the directors
the writers it's gonna be me of course
it's gonna be in fact there's even gonna
be an executive room Kickstarter on the
panel with us talking about Kickstarter
it's gonna be she's flying in from New
York and it's gonna be great and we'll
be able to meet meet our fans and talk
to them we're gonna also show some
footage that we've never shown before
we're gonna unveil some exclusive
footage at the count at Comic Con and
then the next day we're gonna be doing a
signing where we're gonna have an
exclusive poster they're really signing
to a whole bunch of people and and we're
gonna you know we're wearing our Space
Command t-shirts and going to town and
we're gonna have a party where we're
gonna have you know the countdown
because we are our Space Command
Kickstarter campaign ends Saturday night
you know midnight New York time 9:00
p.m. our time so we're gonna have a
count
we're gonna have all of our friends
there and all of our fans who want to
come and we're gonna be in a big room
and we're gonna be cheering and shouting
and you know looking to see how high
that number gets you know tell your
friends tell your family tell your
grandma you know and it's really great
we'll see exactly the date is the panel
is July 13th Friday July 13th room 5 a
and B it's 8:30 to 9:30 p.m. and our
campaign ends the next day's Saturday
July 9th July 14th Saturday July 14th 9
p.m. Pacific time midnight Eastern Time
great and did you schedule I'm going to
do plan your campaign around comic-con
as you know that was a parlor we started
our campaign on coast to coast which is
this radio show that I go in every few
months and it has a huge listenership 5
million people right George Noory and
we've actually cast him in space good
and he's gonna play a character which is
there he told me that the someone said
he would be reincarnated as a talk show
host named Dexter Monterey so we've
actually put that character in Space
Command it's gonna be great fun and so
we started with that and then we're
ending with Comic Con so the idea was
that to anchor the campaign at the
beginning of the at the end so because
again it's you know what's gonna get
attention what's gonna get noticed
what's gonna bang the drum because I
feel enormous ly confident look I'm if I
went doing Space Command I would be
thrilled to be watching Space Command it
would be something I mean you know I was
first in line to see prometheus I'm
amendment I know what I am I know
there's millions of people like me and
so you know so I so I'm thrilled to be
creating something that's exciting to me
and millions of people and you know and
then it's just an obligation of doing it
because the challenge is doing it for a
long number you know 100,000 dollars
sounds like a lot of money to any anyone
but to make a movie let alone a series
of films it's it's a challenge and if I
didn't have the friends I have for
geniuses and special effects genius as a
production genius actors you know it's
because of the people I know that makes
me confident I can do this you know if I
was just starting out I would never
attempt something like this would be
impossible to deliver something with
this amount of effects and this amount
of this scope on this budget no but I
know I can do it because I know what
I've done and I know who
with enzymes so it's cool it seems like
you've been almost wedding the whole
life for this new I have a boss I have I
mean everything I've done all the
hundreds of hours of television all the
books all day everything all the people
I've met you know it's very gratifying
to me that the Damon Lindelof from
Guillermo and all of these dear friends
and showrunners and and a list people
are in favor of what I'm doing I'm
backing what I'm doing Brandon Brackett
just said that he wants to donate to our
campaign Brandon comes up star trekkin
24 and you know terranova you know these
are these are friends and pets very nice
to see their faith in me there's they
have confidence that I can pull this off
and frankly I do too you know it's it's
that that's the other part of it
I wouldn't undertake this I didn't know
if I could do it and do it wonderfully
and so I'm chomping at the bit I can't
wait
and I'm actually we're not waiting I'm
right I'm writing the scripts and and
and we're building sets and building
spacesuits and you know Ian MacKaye who
designed Darth Maul and Queen Amidala is
aboard he's designing aliens and
characters and so we're not good then it
was a different question whether we
would do this or not the only thing I
didn't know is if we could raise the
money on Kickstarter but I was
determined to make this regardless you
know if it was a matter of you know I'm
doing it on you know getting a job at a
restaurant and taking tips and making it
off tips you know whatever whatever
works you know and we were gonna make
this no matter what
and I'm so grateful everybody's healthy
was making any brought on a social media
yes
yeah well we have a whole team of people
who are doing wonderful wonderful things
for us and so so you know Leah our is
helping us and the Greatland and Justin
and visit visiting people EJ and you
know and just
Doug Drexler neil gaiman arm you know
it's like every department someone has
shown up who's just spectacular and you
know and and more the more the merrier
you know if someone comes with a good
heart and the ability to do something
yes it takes an army and you know they
say it takes a village but it's a
village the know stuff and you can't do
it alone it's impossible if you know if
I was anomaly sitting in a room at least
write novels and I think fewer people
but with film and TV know it takes it
takes a ton of people you know and in a
lot and but that's great people aren't
eager to help yeah I'm very grateful
everybody and what is the process you go
through in terms of finding these people
and getting them involved
I used my hypno ray it's like this big
turning we go and they just kind of come
with his glassy eyes no it's it's it's
what I do is I've for many years through
nineteen years I've been running around
table of writers and directors and
actors and producers and composers and
novelists it started 19 years ago when
my friends were feeling bummed out in
Hollywood and they were just isolated
and sad and depressed and and I realized
I could either do something about it or
just complain and I'd set up something
to do something about it so I started a
roundtable where we'd meet every
Thursday so people wouldn't have to
remember which Thursday we meet at a
restaurant and and we would go around
the table and implement would have about
five minutes to talk about what they
were doing and we would then hook them
up with whatever they needed and
everyone will be treated the same
whether they were oscar winners or just
starting out they will be treated with
the same amount of respect and there'd
be no judgment as to as the project i
mean if someone wanted someone to read a
script and give notes fine but you but
no one would ever not say oh well you're
stupid to be doing western or you know
or or that's a silly idea that would not
be allowed because it's not judgment of
material have
unless someone asks for it so it started
with six people and now it's several
thousand and it we have offshoots in the
New York Dallas Phoenix San Francisco
Santa Barbara one starting in London
when starting in New Orleans and and so
you can send one email out it goes out
to all thousand plus members and it's
it's we've thrived and we benefited from
each other so it started with me just
putting out the word to the table and to
my friends in the industry and starting
to build it it started with Neal Johnson
and Doug Drexler my friends were science
fiction directors and Doug's a special
effects guy from Galactica and and then
I just started looking at people who
would show up and but you also look for
talents so spread since David Ragan is
our composer but rath who's a genius at
helping design our campaign and so when
I saw that he was brilliant at it
it's like okay you want to be a
co-producer you're promoted you know so
and then and then other people would
show up and then you start to see who's
just talking and not delivering versus
who's actually doing it and and the only
thing you do is you make course
corrections very quickly because you
it's a two month campaign you can't wait
for six months down the road to see if
someone's oh did done the other thing
they said they were going to do and you
know and but our team is you know
they're people in their 70s helping us
there are people who are kids were in
their teens helping us and all aboard do
that
you know it's fun that they're all
welcome on the spaceship set you have an
interesting perk that yes
well the fun thing about kick-started
you you have perks and so people can
pledge as low as $1 you know and be part
of the part of our our team or and
Kickstarter lasting up to ten thousand
dollars so people get you know walk-ons
in the movie you know all sorts of stuff
and you know that watches and jackets
and your name of books and photos and
posters but we also design on a website
perks that go from fifteen thousand
dollars up to half a million and it was
very fun designing those rewards and
when we got over 250 250 thousand
there's a very fun thing which is one of
the inspirations for Space Command is a
great TV show called Space Patrol that
was on from 1950 to 1955 live television
and I actually met the star of that show
at camera who was quite wonderful a
wonderful man
lemonhead writer norm jolly and they had
the best contest ever which was to the
kid who named the 10th planet planet X
they the winner of that contest got a
full sized copy of their spaceship it
was a 35 foot long spaceship made out of
steel and aluminum delivered on a
flatbed truck it was bigger than the
kid's parents house okay but locally the
10 year olds were worn it and so in
honor of that contest at $250,000
someone will get our entire spaceship
set it'll be delivered on a flatbed
truck to the winner but then anything
what's what can we do to beat that well
at half a million what could someone get
for half a million bucks 500,000 and we
said ok here we go
they get first of all to get a
red-carpet premiere in their hometown so
they can invite all their friends plus
they get an actual trip into space a
real trip so there are a number of
carriers now offering an actual trip
into space legitimate carriers and so
they'll get a ticket on one of those
spaceships so that's pretty cool so if
someone's just sitting around the house
thinking about what to do with that half
million that they don't need please you
know gone to you know with our Space
Command website and
rock'n'roll mark you were able to raise
75,000 on Kickstarter in three days for
your Space Command project what was your
strategy when you launched this campaign
what did you find worked and what did
you find did not work well you know I've
sold over 100 scripts all the studios in
the network's and in those cases I
didn't have to raise the money for
instance when I was a producer on
sliders we had a 2012 order our budget
was 1.3 million per episode I didn't
have to race that money so although I
knew I can write and I know I can write
and direct to produce I never raise
funds before I didn't know if I would
succeed so the first thing I did was I
treated it as a something new I had to
learn and I spent several months talking
to people learning how to do it building
a team shooting the video and really
putting effort into the video because
that would be you know what I'd be using
sure I could do the project and buddies
enough all to work I didn't know if I
could raise money at all
and now we're up to one hundred fifty
eight thousand we still have several
week you know a number of weeks ago
we're going to be having a panel at
Comic Con
so there's when 158 is not our final
number by any means and so so what I
basically did was I realized I had to
treat it with respect
and but I welcome that I welcome
learning a new thing but I had no
assumption that I would succeed and
going in with that attitude actually was
very helpful because then it became a
continual learning process and and and
the main thing I also knew was that you
had to be in direct communication day by
day with your backers with your audio
you couldn't just stop pushing the big
red button and then you know walking
away that that's I think like a lot of
people's family did you research
due diligence no yeah well fortunately I
run a round table of writers and
directors and actors and producers and
you meet every Thursday and we've been
doing that for 19 years that's several
thousand people and so I put out the
word on my table saying if anyone knows
about Kickstarter please send me
information so I got a lot of response
and so I started researching successful
campaigns like Double Fine and some of
the things Neil Gaiman was doing and
then ultimately Neil showed me the
campaign with his wife Amanda Palmer was
doing and so I was learning from that
and and then just kind of course
correcting as I went and some things you
do don't work and some things you do do
work and and then also you build a team
and so when someone shows up wants to
help first of all you find out what
their skills are and then you say okay
well let's see if they're actually going
to do it rather than just
now what's really is also amazing is how
fast everything is there's instantaneous
response and so it could be a 24/7 job
if you let it but you also have to not
get exhausted because you have to keep
up with their head to be able to do your
job how much time limited pre-planning
us a couple months two or three months
yeah and and that was both shooting the
video and also just what you know
reading up on Kickstarter talking to
people learning and but also actually
launched about a month later than we
intended something because we had to
make some fun further tweaks and we were
refining the project because also that's
the other part of it you're also working
on the project as well that the series
of films and you're developing the
concept builds and grows and people will
give you input and then you so you your
responsive to that it really is a very
direct two-way conversation now the
video is excellent thanks and I'm
wondering how much fun you put into
planning that because you have so many
elements you have the personal element
where we miss you and other people in
your ensemble but then you also have the
fun stuff in the back yes
well it was it was put whole months in
on on the video and part of it one thing
I recognized with Kickstarter that was
very very clear is that you have to have
the personal touch it's the person the
individual saying hi this is Who I am
I really would like your help it's
usually one person whether it's Double
Fine or Amanda Palmer it's usually the
the the one-on-one unfortunately I was a
commentator on Morning Edition for three
years long ago and I've done a lot of
media interviews and so I'm very
comfortable with that and I think that
helped but also in my campaign it was me
as a person but it was also this is the
body of work I've done and then the
third part is this is a team I've
assembled and it's an amazing team and
then it was the special effects shots
that we were generating fresh saying
this is what what we're doing is going
to look like so it wasn't just you can
look at our work from the past but
there's no telling what we're gonna do
now here's something very concrete that
we generated new specific to this
project and that was very important
because otherwise people are gonna be
dubious but if you say okay look look at
this if you like this if you like these
effect shots if you like these actors
who are gonna be casting then you've got
a pretty good idea about what we're up
to
how did you choose your incentives
that's a long time to in terms of
choosing the incentives we looked at
other campaigns we thought about
ourselves as geeks and what we'd like
because I when I was a kid
Star Trek they viewed the original Star
Trek and I was a huge Star Trek fan and
and they were very slow in terms of
merchandising products from Star Trek
initially they're very few and I'd
longed for a different you know model
kits and action figures and why phasers
and all that stuff so I'm just kind of
thinking about me as a fan and then what
would appeal to me and what would I like
to have and what would be interesting
and it was a mixture of several things
because I was thinking about the
different kind of people who would be
pledging to Space Command and so there
would be the fans which the
science-fiction fans they loved a bit be
part of this and maybe at a Space
Command watch or a Space Command jacket
then there were also the people who
might be visual effects people and maybe
they want to be part of the team or they
want to learn from what we're doing so
there's also the how-to aspect so I
actually posted something called the one
minute film school that's about how you
pitch a script how you you know write
write a movie how you direct a movie
with my friends and like Guillermo del
Toro and my friend Michael making
directs Battlestar Galactica in these
videos talking about those things and
then there's another part of it that
might be aspiring actors who might want
to be part of the project so they might
want to walk on a walk-on role or a
speaking role
or there might be someone wants to have
a producer credit and so they can put
money in and get a producer credit so so
I was thinking about the different
reasons that someone might be interested
and how they might want to participate
and those are different sort of pie
wedges of the whole of Hope High and so
you have to mind mindful of that as well
there's not one size fits all we talked
about how we mentioned earlier things to
a critical mass and just sort of the
things aligned and it I momentum bills
yes what starts with doing the work but
the work has to be a high quality but
you have to put it out into the world
and get there's some people who are on
your wavelength but the fun fun part is
that there are people if you're doing
work that has honesty and it's well-made
and has and communicates what you're
trying to communicate there are people
all up and down the food chain in
Hollywood from from from people who are
its kind of marginal to people who are
incredibly successful will resonate to
your work will respond to it the
challenge is that getting it in front of
them and so it's very important
interests of doing the work to target
the people who are doing work that you
admire I always suggested people that
they make a list of a hundred writers
directors actors producers even studio
executives who are doing the work that
they most admire so for instance if you
see a TV show and you like it add that
those names to your list then particular
if you're in Los Angeles or New York or
any of the major cities with cities but
particularly la show that list your
friends and say if you see these people
any of these names giving talks and
hearing on panels let me know because
then you can go to those places and you
can talk to those people you can meet
them and you can start to establish
connection and and then they get to be
curious about you and then if you say
well I've done this feature you know
here you know it's then what the great
rules of Hollywood is then everybody
needs to read so script is a very quiet
and a very obnoxious object so it's like
oh do I really have to read that script
but if you say I've made a film it's
much easier and or even if it is short
where people can just put it in the DVD
player or click it you know on
online or whatever we can watch at the
kind of an immediate experience your
it's a much better commercial for you as
a creative artist than just a script and
I speak as someone who's actually sold a
lot of scripts you know and you know I
have hundreds of hours of produce
credits so so I've been successful
pitching scripts selling scripts all
that stuff but I'm much favored making
the thing itself because when you make
the thing itself it's such a better
advertisement for you first of all and
secondly you're no longer auditioning
you're actually creating work but but
you can't just create the work and
expect the work magically to find its
audience so that's where you have to do
the heavy lifting but the cool part is
and thanks to the internet everyone is
checking stuff out and the moment is
very permeable so the moment someone
who's a buddy of JJ Abrams emails JJ
says oh but you gotta check this out
well it has to be someone he knows but
then you never know if you just start
putting out in the world to the people
you know particular you know there's
gonna be a ripple effect and even with
space come in that's what's been
happening where people know about people
if you heard about it and and it's just
you know so then it's just really doing
recognizing the part of your job is
creating the working part of your job is
getting the work out there and most
artists don't want to do that second
part they think you know it's hard you
know I don't want to do that particular
writers it's like I want to send my room
and type and I don't want to talk to
people you know well you know tough you
know you either get some get it get a
partner who's very outgoing or learn
those skills because it is a very
frustrating life to write scripts
endlessly and have them
nowhere and so you should not allow that
to be acceptable in your career in your
life and so you have to be the good to
be the guy that pushes the rock of the
mount and it's funny if a couple years
ago I made a Star Trek episode without
studio or network that was called Star
Trek new voyages world and often time
and it starts George Takei and it was a
full hour-long episode we made it in
2007 2008 got nominated for the Hugo and
the nebula and but it was very difficult
and my mantra to myself while I was i
co-wrote it and directed it and
executive produced it and my mantra to
myself while I was making it was I'm
made of iron and nothing will stop me
and I found that I need to really live
by that to get that made and so if you
take something like that on and if
you're determined gets the finish line
no matter what then it becomes a
question of how do I do this how do I
make it possible who do I need to
affiliate with what I'm what do I need
to remove that isn't necessary and and
and you'll be very clearly trying to
accomplish because most people get
stopped
most people get stuck most people go
nowhere and you have to have a very keen
eye that's what the problem is to be
able to fix it so that's part of it in
terms of people not going places
yes let's suppose someone's imaging
script yes and they'll see they're in
their 30s they have a literary agent
they know that they're talented yes
scripts they've won or their once free
running contest they've made the rounds
yet nothing's caught on right that
happens a lot yeah and there's a lot
making a living as a writer what was
your title a brain surgeon I know it's
seriously the it happens a lot and then
it becomes a question of how committed
well first of all what are you trying to
accomplish and how committed are you to
accomplishing it because you have to be
clear on if your goal is to get rich and
famous or if your goal is to do
meaningful work I personally in my
career in my life I favor the latter is
an objective because if your goal is to
get rich and famous well then what you
need to do is find people who've gotten
rich and famous and have them mentor you
because it's a recipe and you need to
follow it so that's one that's one part
of the answer but the other part of the
answer is if your goal is do meaningful
work then get a Canon 5d learn Final Cut
on a Mac you know make the work you know
go to science fiction conventions meet
science fiction actors if you want to
science fiction movies they're very
accessible go where or go to film
festivals and meet actors who aren't
science fiction actors meet actors
befriends them you know get them to be
in your project but make the project for
the lowest possible number you can make
it for while still having it be of
quality and so that's where you need to
meet people have the skill sets that you
need you have to have good sound
absolutely you have to have a picture
that looks good or well that used to get
a good DP but there's tons of those
people so but on the other hand if you
want one place to do gaming cells
studios and climb that ladder and make
millions of dollars the way you do that
is you move to LA you go to every event
you can where someone you admire is
speaking you go to the writers go then
you go to the events of the American
Cinematheque on the DGA you
then you learn your craft you get good
at writing you have people read your
script and give you notes for more
professional screenwriters not
screenwriting teachers it's very
important when you're getting notes from
someone to ask yourself have they ever
written and sold a script if they
haven't then how are you going to learn
what you need to learn that successful
career if you're learning it from
someone who's never done it I mean it's
possible you can learn that but it's
much harder so for instance what the I
advise people I mean people can hire me
to read scripts and give notes that's
fine
but they can also reach out if you had
ten of your favorite screenwriters you
could write them care of the writers
guild you just put on the envelope
please forward the four letters don't
send a whole bunch of the time that's in
one of the time and you save that writer
you send these one at a time let's say
you choose 15 of your favorite
screenwriters you say I've written the
screenplay I'd like to pay you a
thousand dollars to read it and give me
notes I promise you one of them will say
yes because they are never offered money
to read scripts they were always at
having people read scripts for free the
reason you don't say all fifteen at once
is if you get 15 yeses you're out 15
credit but the point is let's say you
get some a-list screenwriter to read
your script and give you notes if you
response when he likes it amazing things
can happen so but don't don't require
that don't have that being an
expectation because even if he just
gives you notes you're miles ahead he
just has to be someone who's writing in
a genre that's similar to yours are
writing in a tome that's similar to
yours so he's going to be get what
you're up to but but that's what I would
recommend because
you know I mean some of the
screenwriting teachers are good some of
the screenwriting gurus but a lot of
them you know are just going on
guesswork or they're throwing up a lot
of rules that basically I feel that the
more rules someone lays down in terms of
what a script needs to be the less they
know what they're doing because in
reality when you get really good at
writing you hear the music and structure
becomes second nature it's like that
it's like the bones of a house you're
building in house you know how a house
has to stand the bigger the story the
more elaborate that bones of the house
but but that becomes almost second
nature it's like breathing and then it's
just finding the truth of the story
having the characters be alive it's it's
as I said stirring the music it's not
like oh by page seven I need to have
this happen to my page twelve I need
this to happen by I mean the big
structure basically is simply start with
someone who has a problem you would give
them the deepest possible if it's
happy I mean they give themselves out of
it if it's a tragedy they fail to you
know that's structure and you know you
can also study movies that you love and
take them apart you can sort of you know
human record them on audio and listen to
it and that helps you analyze it better
you can listen to a movie to analyze the
the writing you can turn the sound off
and watch a movie to analyze the
directing and seeing how this is how it
works as a series of shots and movement
within those shots so those are two
things that I do in terms of finding
ways of course
want to have look at your work or
intense contact with I think there's a
fine line in LA so many people are being
pitched how aggressive do you get
because you don't want to turn personal
you know and one person was once a
writer was once asked when you take no
for an answer he said when they call
security but I don't really subscribe to
that the real answer is first of all
treat people the way you would want to
be treated so don't be a jerk I mean for
one thing I mean you have no monoi you
have no idea how many people in various
circumstances will Jam me up against a
wall and start pitching their story to
me it's like mr. t mr. t yeah you hear
this okay okay faded we open on the sky
and we see clouds we see Birds
it's just spire and it's the Empire
State Building we're down at 102nd floor
hugging first 100 God you know no please
no and first of all when you're pitching
never pitch every beat every shot no
yeah if the broad-strokes but also you
shouldn't because she is that person
buying stories why are you pitching to
them what's in it for them you know it's
like but also no one likes to be pitched
in a you know in a social circumstance
or if they're giving a talk it's like do
I really want to enter listen for 20
minutes someone's story that I've known
for them from the first minute is awful
know about what you want to do is always
add first of all if you go to bed
who you admire is speaking you remember
the
we rule of three rule of three is most
people make the mistake of immediately
pitching or immediately you know yeah
I'm an actor you gotta cast me out
here's my head shot here's my reel you
don't know you have not established
relationship with that person it's the
first time you meet them at an event you
just say something truthful maybe about
their work but it has to be specific it
has to be you know there was that scene
in that movie you did with who I was
talking to his mother and you know I had
this really difficult relationship with
my mother when I saw that scene it open
the door in me somehow and I when I had
a conversation with my mom and it
changed our relationship that's
something that's gonna resonate
that's something truthful and meaningful
from your heart but don't gush and don't
go on at length okay because there's
many other people who want to talk to
this this guy the other part so then you
go to a second event with that person
you see and if you have a chance at the
end to talking again say oh hi mister
so-and-so you know last time when we
spoken I told you about my mom you said
such-and-such it really meant so much to
me that that you you really cared you
know or you say something again it's
like you know its thing and I just want
to let you know how many how much that
meant to me right okay then you go to
the third event the third of him you run
and then I see you've got she'll keep
running into each others like we're
swimming in the same aquarium and you
know it's like you know it's something
you've been so kind talking in his last
two times and there's something you said
last time we talked I really applied it
it really you know maybe this film or
Bluff about whatever then usually you
know also I didn't I you know I'm read
in the trades that you're looking for a
Western and you know and based on this
conversation I'm having I just thought I
don't know if you'd be open to a vibrant
Western I'd love to have my
representation send it to you if you'd
be open to that or you know whatever the
request is you say in a very respectful
manner you don't want at length you stop
it yes or if he says no that's fine you
let it go the point is by then is that I
gotten a sense that you're not a jerk
cuz you didn't push the button the first
moment and secondly he's kind enough
about you where he's intrigued about you
you know so that's that's the way you do
it or if that's one way to do it another
way to do it by the way is if you go to
any event and we're like let's say JJ
Abrams his truck is talking at the event
now everyone's gonna find is owned in on
JJ but his people are gonna be in that
first row okay any any of these bigwigs
okay
and if you google who their partners are
and Google image what those people look
like you know what those people look
like some cept I talked to JJ you try to
talk to his right-hand guy or James a
James Cameron you talk to his right-hand
guy because therefore one thing I'll be
Adele admire the fact that you've done
your homework so you know who they are
and you know but again there's always
treat people with respect always people
like didn't wanted to treat it it's not
about the fast hustle it's not about oh
my god I'm gonna pitch this they're
gonna love it they're gonna buy it no
you're building a career and the careers
made out of relationships and careers
about doing the work and what games
respect is if you let's say you meet
someone like Brian Burke who's JJ's
partner and you say you know and you do
research you know a little bit about
them and say you know I read that your
first you know first shot you ever
produced was about you know a boy who
had the wooden leg whatever doesn't hurt
you say Brian Burke you know it's funny
I you know I looked at that short online
that was just so moving a friend of mine
you know my name is a kid is you know
terrible train actually lost his legs
knees become no you know decathlon
athlete and I'm doing this this little
piece about him and you know it's just
then you really inspired me so Brian
Burke will say wow that's really great
the next time you see probably but you
say you know I'm sorry you were so
encouraging last time you spoken I've
I've actually finished the short and I'd
love to send it to you the fact that you
said you were gonna do something and
then you did it and I'm not talking
about Brian Burke please don't everyone
we talked to Brian Burke but but the
fact you did 99.9% of people in this
town or in this industry they say
they're gonna do something and they
never do it which is why if you have a
screenplay and the money isn't attached
or the actors aren't attached that's why
they blow you off because most stuff
never gets anywhere and so why should
they put more effort in your project
that you're gonna put in your project
but if you actually do it let's say you
make that documentary and it's great
then they start that will be coming
and they want to help you because they
see that you're serious and everything
in my career has been about saying I'm
going to do something and then doing it
I'm very strong on that I'm very firm on
that in my own career I'm very hard on
myself and very committed but people
that then establishes the of integrity
and once people get that integrity and
authenticity are very important and once
people see you've got that they trust
you to a certain degree and then they'll
help you so it's worth it works that way
you mentioned in previous videos that
you know breaking into film and
television is really not that difficult
blue as long as you know what you're
doing and you apply yourself with
dedication and consistency yes
so going back to that same thing and
keeping your commitment not only to
others but yourself what is dedication
and consistency to you even on a daily
basis discipline is very important my
mom I was with my I was raised by a
single mom and at one point one of her
boyfriends was a retired spy who was
also a writer and he said one of the
best things I ever heard about writing
he said in terms of writing said an
amateur can rely on inspiration a
professional needs discipline absolutely
and so so minimally five days a week off
in six days a week I'm I'm working you
know and and even on Space Command it's
almost 24/7 now and we're I'm just kind
of I'm it's my job and I and I love it
but I also treat it seriously you know
I'm a writer and I have to write and if
I'm also producing and directing I have
to do those jobs and I'm not looking for
someone else to do the hard part I'm
doing the hard part you know and but
beyond that I also study successful
people whom I admire and a big part of
my conversation with those people is how
they divide their day and so for
instance Ray Bradbury was a dear dear
friend and a very
very wonderful mentor for many many
years dearly missed you know he I found
out his his writing schedule was five
days a week Monday through Friday he
would write for three hours in the
morning then he would have lunch and
take a nap and then do business in the
afternoon his write you know the
business owner of his writing career and
then evenings and weekends for his
family and he that he did that for 80
years yeah so you know 70 75 years and
it worked really well and so that's the
best writing schedule of anyone I know
but but but when you're a writer
producer director divides up differently
so for instance I'm not writing nearly
as much as I normally would be because
I'm running the space command campaign
but because I see that the job is
getting those films made it's not about
me clocking pages every day it's about
getting the films made I'm clear on what
my job is but but also you know the
moment you say if no one picked me how
would I still get to the finish line
you're free because then you don't need
anybody to say yes you just figure out
how to do it yourself
and five ten years ago that would have
been much harder for the old days if you
were shooting on thirty five millimeter
or 16 millimeter making a feature would
cost millions of dollars you'd be move
editing on a movie Ola rent distribution
would be a nightmare because it's like
the studios and networks have all that
stuff locked up if you want to reach an
audience and millions good luck if you
don't have those guys aboard now it's a
totally different ballgame if you can if
you you know part of space command was I
you know my goal since I was 13 years
old was to be a showrunner on my own
science-fiction show I was thinking to
myself the other day how can I get
what's the fastest route to doing that I
help I can remove the studios and
networks I can remove the middleman and
go directly to that and that's why I've
been doing this I Kickstarter because I
don't need them and I'm not I don't
consider them the enemy but if I don't
need them if I'm if I don't need to be
wealthy if I don't need to be making
millions that liberates me I'm free I
keep my overhead very low I've earned
millions as a writer but I'm not ruled
by money and because of that I don't
need to work I don't want to do it's
free I'm free and so in terms of getting
Korean film and TV writing a lot and
getting better and better and better and
making sure your work is solid is vital
getting feedback from people who really
know what they're talking about is vital
getting people to consider your work to
look at your work banging the drum for
yourself is vital but doing it in a way
that's it's funny I had lunch a little
while ago with Nicholas Meyer who
directed Wrath of Khan wonderful writer
director and and he said the way you
have a career in this industry is charm
with persistence
and he's absolutely right where you say
persistence with charm either way but
the point is you're an absolute squeaky
wheel for yourself but in a charming way
so people don't think gee what an
kid you don't want them to be
saying that about you I mean there's
some really horrible alpha dogs in this
industry who are very successful but if
you can do things with grace and
consideration one of most probably the
most the single most polite personally I
know is JJ Abrams his manners are
impeccable astonishing he's so
considerate he's such a great guy and so
if he can be on top of the food chain
then it means you don't have to be a
jerk to make it in this town you know
Guillermo tap to Guillermo del tomorrow
with him I'm doing a book he's a
wonderful guy big heart big heart it's
just wonderful and you know so that's
that's how I run my life to I want I
want to really be talking to detail
about having a career in film and
television because them because the big
difference between having a Korean film
and television with studios in the
networks versus having career as an
filmmaker or making your own web series
is simply the difference between wealth
and poverty financial wealth and poverty
because the studios are the networks
have the money and if you're in the
writer scale or the DGA there are
minimums guaranteed minimums make you
know it's you'll earn a lot more money
and that's great wealth is very nice
having a lot of money is very nice but
but so in terms of cracking with that
it's just
you must meet these people face-to-face
you must go where they are and and
because if you're in you know East
McKeesport Pennsylvania we're in
Connecticut or in the Bay Area you know
you're just not going to run into these
people they're here they're here in Los
Angeles so the first step is you move
here and you meet as many people as you
can possibly meet and you learn how to
say in one sentence the thing with
legitimizes you so Fran and you and by
the way every studio network has a
fellowship a writing fellowship you can
enter those that are Muslim or for free
the Nichols fellowship also all the
studios and networks and
he's monitored those if you win those
it's a big step in getting a career if
you win the ABC disney fellowship they
give you $50,000 in a career so so
that's the thing i would advocate for
everybody it's much better now than it
used to be when I was writing The
Twilight Zone companion I saw a photo of
the crew and first of all they were all
in suit and tie which I thought was very
amusing for a crew and but secondly they
were all white males with the except
with the one exception of the script
girl who was a white female and now you
could be african-american you can be a
female and be a showrunner you can you
know yes Hollywood is aegis and rate and
racist and sexist but it's better than
it used to be it just is so and also by
the way any time you encounter those
kind of problems you don't get defeated
by them you say okay I'm gonna get
around that wall for that wall under
that wall I'm gonna break through that
wall I'm gonna it's it's it's irrelevant
it's not it's relevant it's an
impediment but it shouldn't stop you
because there are plenty of people who
succeed despite those things and so
that's that's a big part of it - also -
you started out writing in your early
20s and
well my first short story I sold when I
was 19 and I was having gallery shows of
my art with photography when I was
teenager so in my first radio play yeah
I wrote when I was 18 and it aired when
I was 18 so I was pretty fast out of the
gate so and I was writing my first book
at 22 The Twilight Zone companion and I
was writing for TV by the time I was 22
or 23 yeah yeah how was that being so
young did you have certain it was great
oh it was well I was very lucky because
when I was kid the Twilight Zone
and Star Trek and Outer Limits the
original versions of those shows were
the things that made me want to be a
writer particularly television writer
when I was 13 I read a book called the
making of Star Trek it was the first
book I ever read about how to make a TV
show and in the first writer I ever saw
in person was Ray Bradbury he spoke at a
library when I was 10 so all of these
things started percolating in my mind
and when I was a kid I also got a visit
as a Christmas present I was given a
visit to the Star Trek set and so I got
I was there for the filming of the last
episode of the original Star Trek I was
on the enterprise sets which was just
great
and so so I knew I sort of had a sense
of calling I knew I would be an artist
or a writer from a very early age I was
drawing and writing and reading science
fiction voraciously and comic books and
watching TV and going to movies so I was
very lucky in that way and so and I also
also because I saw the Ray Bradbury and
Rod Serling were writing books and
movies and TV shows I had that sense of
you could go up between between all
through all three and that was very
useful to andhraite one thing that Ray
said to me is it's very important to to
do all three particularly keep writing
books because then they can't own you
and no single rejection can stop you so
so Ray had a lot of movies he brought
that never got made I have I have the
script of the Martian Chronicles that
Railroad for MGM in 1963 it was going to
be the movie that Gregory Peck and
Robert Moulton we're going to
right after to kill a mockingbird is a
great script and it never got me and
I've got an original copy of that signed
by Ray and which I read in little tiny
pieces
every day at lunch when I was a producer
on sliders just to kind of take as long
as possible to read this wonderful
script it was great who you mentioned
Ray Bradbury b1 German yes where were
some of you other mentors and in terms
of so you said you observed people and
is good at that
what did you actually observe with these
mentors that maybe they didn't
articulate to you what you saw this
being secrets of their success yes well
I think two of the things that okay
here's the reason I'm a professional
writer as opposed to someone sitting in
a bar all day long bitter and saying
that kind of point of TV going though
shows I should have been writing for
those shows and Hollywood sucks I hate
everything you know I could've been that
guy I just you know still might be you
know the day is young but but the but
what it was was when I was 16 my mother
went to Sears and bought this really
weird piece of furniture there was a
table with two beds that would go in and
got at right angles to each other under
you tuck him under the table then you
pull them out to sleep on it was a
weirdest damn thing I have no idea where
she why she bought it which is putting
the living room of our apartment but it
also had an am/fm radio built into that
table and we don't have a ham radios but
never FM radios and so one night when I
was 16 I started twirling the dial and
about 10:00 at night on a Friday and I
started hearing something amazing which
was science fiction writers talking
about their craft and it was a radio
show called hour 25 and for the first
time I started hearing all the writers I
grew up reading Robert Heinlein and I
marvin arthur c clarke and Ray Bradbury
and Theodore sturgeon all these great
science fiction writers in Harlan
Ellison talking about writing and and
and many of them in Britain for Star
Trek uh Ted sturgeon and Harlan and
Richard Matheson and and and I started
hearing them talk about writing and
Harlan was talking about science we can
write in workshop called clarion Writers
Workshop and was the leading science
fiction writing workshop in the country
and it was six weeks long 25 students at
Michigan State University in the summer
and each week a different famous science
fiction writer who lived with you in the
dorms and you would write like crazy and
critique each other's stories and I
thought I want to go to that so even
though I was an art student at UCLA I
got enrolled in the art school by
mistake it was a clerical error I never
applied to that major but I got a degree
in it because it was you know why not
that's another story but but when I was
19 I went to clearing and it was six
very famous science fiction writers and
then I sold my first short story but I
also learned from those riders in the
mean that I learned was that they were
just like me that if they could do it I
could it was Roger Zelazny chin Samuel r
Delaney Joe Haldeman Kate Wilhelm Damon
Knight Gene Wolfe and and Damon Knight
one of the students asked him which of
us do you think will make it as
professional writers and he should not
have answered that question but he did
and even he's named several and they all
became very very famous writers and I
was where the ones he thought would not
make it and the next day he bought my
first short story print ontology he was
everything which taught me first of all
that no one can predict your future no
one has a right to rob you of your
future and he could not look into my
secret soul and see how determined I was
he could not look into my heart and he
couldn't even predict the future 24
hours ahead and so so my point my point
is that if someone says something
negative you if they say you're never
gonna make it as a writer say four words
to them that will get them to go away
and those four words are you're the
Antichrist and and they'll go away
because no one has a right to take away
from you all they can say as I read your
script and from my point of view this is
where it's not working that's all they
can say they have no right to say
anything else but so so from meeting
those professional writers I sold my
first short story I was fifty bucks
my so my first I was fifty bucks my next
L was twenty thousand
and that was for the Twilight soul
companion that was the advance and but
but then when I got back to UCLA Ted
sturgeon Theodore sturgeon was a Star
Trek writer who written great science
fiction books and novels I grew up
reading he was teaching an adult
education class and as an undergrad I
wasn't allowed to take the adult
education classes by thought well you
know hell with that it's tedsters I'm
gonna take it and so another rule I
would say is anything with disempowers
you ignore it if there's rules they're
set against you ignore them you just do
what your heart tells you to do as long
as you don't harm anyone you know you
don't want to be you know hurtful to
others but in that case I just signed up
with class and one of the and the
teaching and Ted became Theodore
sturgeon became one of my mentors when I
was 19 so there was a there was a
teaching assistant in the inner
sturgeons class his name was Michael
Reeves and he had just come out of
Clarion a year or two before me and he
had been riding professionally and he
was just trying to write animation and
for the network's
and so we became friends and when I got
out of college he said well you know I'm
right for this show called space stars
and they had Space Ghost it was a
hanna-barbera and he asked if I'd like
to collaborate with him cuz he was
writing all the episodes and and I said
sure and and then we wrote for Smurfs
together and that was very clear that I
could write these on my own so I just
started writing animation I was very
quickly in animation but my heart really
wasn't that wasn't my one to be so I
then turned enough to live for the year
from my writing animation I can earn
about $100,000 in three months which is
a lot back then and because I was the
god of animation I was doing very very
well in that arena and and I stole all
my employers that I was going to take
time off to write this live-action
screenplay and I wouldn't be available
this it's great and the day I stopped to
write the screenplay they started
calling me with offers of animation work
and I had to turn down $200,000 in two
days and that Rex you're writing day so
then from then on I wrote at UCLA where
they couldn't reach me it was before
cellphones and I would just check my
answer machine at the end of the day so
I could write and I finished that
screenplay and it's sold and I got me
piloting with NBC and that pilot got
made and I was off and running in
live-action writing for the networks and
the studios so my point in that is you
must take a stand free where you're
going and what you believe and even if
you're doing well you if it's not your
dream you must take a stand and be
willing to take the heart the licks take
the blows and be willing to to take the
losses in the in addition but at the
point that I was getting out before that
is because I had Theodore sturgeon
mentoring me that led to me Mike meeting
Michael Reeves was a professional who
brought me into television so it wasn't
me writing spec scripts and trying to
get an agent to take me or anything like
that it was someone opening a door for
me through a friendship through that but
I also you know I could write so and at
the same time I was writing The Twilight
Zone companion at 22 to because when I
got out of UCLA UCLA I knew I wanted to
be a writer producer in television there
were no classes in that so I thought
well how do I learned this and I said
well why don't I think one of the
greatest shows ever made and learn how
it was made and then by emulating the
people who made it I can do that job we
can learn that job so it was two years
after Rod Serling's death and I was 22
years old I'd sold one short story if
I'd asked a hundred people how how
likely it was that Rod Serling's Widow
would let me write that book a hundred
people would have said no no you have no
chance which is why your future in your
career is not a majority opinion it's
your opinion and what I did was because
she'd already turned down major
journalists and so I couldn't go
directly to her she'd have said no so
what I did was I met one writer who
worked on The Twilight Zone in the
science-fiction dimension so I
interviewed him his name was George
Clayton Johnson and I asked him who he
knew that I could also interview so he
connect me up with a couple of people
and they connected me up with a couple
of people and over three months maybe
even 30 people who have worked on The
Twilight Zone by then I knew a lot about
the subject I felt very confident I
could pull this off and then I went to
Carol Serling and it was at rods house
it was exactly as he left it there was
one room just for the awards it was
Sammis the Peabody Awards the three
hugo's and there were two living rooms
there was a Olympic sized pool his
office was a building back of the house
all the books were their own scrapbooks
the film's Kansas Twilight Zone episode
16 millimeter prints and film cans
stacked high in the garage and then
upstairs in the Attic were his
scrapbooks his scripts his files
I literally crawled from rostov Rod
Serling's attic which was great and but
but after three months I met with Carol
Sterling and I stood there and I told
her she was sitting I was standing and I
just kind of pitched what I was going to
do and then she must have talked to the
people I interviewed who she trusted and
they said well this kid Olivia him pull
it off and she didn't said you have full
access to everything and I went through
where all the scrapbooks all the files
everything I interviewed over 100 people
the book came out it was a huge success
it's selling printed sold over half a
million copies and the New York Times
named it one of ten science fiction
books for the ages in 2006 and I was the
only non-fiction book on that list so
Ray Bradbury and I were on that list so
it's so much fun to go over to raise
that day and say hey we're both on this
list in the New York Times that was just
as a great moment it all starts with
doing the work the work is what
impresses people with you and so you do
the you do your work first and so and
sometimes have an amazing benefit so for
instance I am when I was producing
sliders they made a miniseries of Moby
Dick and Gregory Peck was in at his
father Mapple doing this this sermon and
they cast him cos he played eight have
in the 1950s movie that John Huston
directed so I met I went to the
screening and Charlie Peck was in the
row behind me and asked nope I suppose I
could mail him a lobby card of Bobby
taking signed it and Ray Bradbury
written that that movie for John Huston
but it was live but it was basically
felt at the time that the Gregory Peck
was miscast he wasn't perfect as they
have please great his father Mapple he
won an Emmy for that in the miniseries
and so I got this weird idea cuz I come
upon this with this record album with
Charles Laughton
in an audio adaptation of Moby Dick and
he was great he was this brilliant actor
and so I made I edited together this
audio version of Moby Dick that had
Charles Laughton as Ahab
Gregory Peck his father Mapple in
Richard Basehart as Ishmael and I gave
it out as a Christmas present my friends
one year as a CD and I never would have
had the temerity to be able to rape
robbery because I was screwing with his
work but one day I come home and there's
a message on my answering machine and
says hello mr. Zachary this is Ray
Bradbury I've just heard your Moby Dick
CD and please call me I think Oh God
I pissed off Ray Bradbury's I called him
fling my throat and he says I was dear
friends with Charles Maude and I love
what you did it's so wonderful please
you've got to come over the house let's
let's let's let's sit down and talk
great so I went to Ray's house this is
you know 10 or 15 years ago about 15 and
and I and we sat down we talked and
became fast friends and so from then on
every month or two I'd go to his house
we just hang out and talk and he became
this great friends great mentor to me a
great adviser but it came from me doing
this work that I had no expectation of
getting anything from I just wanted to
create something that would entertain me
and my friends and it entertained Ray
Bradbury too and we became friends so
that's another great way that you can do
something that will get many doors to
open by creating your truth coming from
creative delight and just following
through on it